Kilda and welcome everyone today we have
the katakira up first and then the
prayer at the end
ing
[Music]
a more teenager please be seated
thank you
foreign
thank you for showing up in person today
and coming along and being being
involved I could see the TV cameras here
again and
um we will get right into it do we have
any apologies
no apologies thank you uh declaration is
a conflict of interest
uh Council Stringer I.E conflict of
interest with a gender item 5i
thank you counselor we can do that
separately
any other conflicts
thank you counselors
and any urgent late business
thank you councilors
first up on the agenda is the
independent review to restore confidence
in the gore District Council
now unless there's any objection around
the table this report and
recommendations are going to be tabled
the reason for this is given that the
council has recently engaged with a new
KC so senior Council it's felt that it
would be appropriate to have
legal Representatives look over this
before we engage in the review
uh and it would be inappropriate to
accept them at this time before while
we're still still working on them just
to bring them back at a later date to
potentially change them
do we have any objection around the
table to tabling that report
uh no objection
happy to move on just a commentary your
worship uh councilor Richmond Farm yeah
just um obviously support that the
matter should be tabled
um from myself I believe it's wise uh
way to be moving forward this morning uh
this afternoon uh and obviously
um support the fact that we can review
that at a later date
thank you councilor and I may have not
clarified there but I just wanted to
clarify for the public uh that are
watching here today that the review will
still be happening um it's just fine
just finalizing those details around the
terms of reference
any further questions
did you still have one Council Stringer
oh yeah thanks to worship I was just
going to ask um do we have the ability
during this period to further refine it
from the council side of things or is
that process finished
uh leaving on the table uh will mean
that our legal counsel can review this
and give us further advice and I'm sure
that a council will be able to comment
on it before it comes and comes back to
the table
thank you counselor
any further comment before we move on
thank you councilors
moving on to the drafts
2023-2024 annual plan Point number five
now I'm into interpretation on how to uh
go about this with the number of
recommendations on the table I might
just open it up for discussion at this
point in time uh but first I will just
ask whether
uh lornay would like to speak to this
report at all
thank you euroship I think I can take
the report as read we have heard a
couple of really good sessions with
elector members and the briefing
sessions that we've had so the issues
should be well known to to the elector
members staff have put a lot of time in
effort into trying to find find savings
where we can and we leave it in the
illegal member's hands to guide us where
we go next
I think it's that Lorne
did we want to open it full discussion
or did we want to go through the
recommendations one by one Council hover
may I ask a couple of questions before
we start the discussion
um so there's a recommendation
um here in terms of the percentage
increase and I'm wondering how that
actually applies to what people will
receive in the mail
people in the urban areas have a annual
uniform or sorry a uniform charge and we
also have a split between rural and
urban rates so while we've got a general
figure here what will happen next or is
there any
automatic things that do happen
um
the universal uniform and neural General
charge is generally around 25 that's
been the council's practice in previous
years to keep it at 25 so that this is a
fair reflection on both urban and rural
um the whilst the average increase is
11.56 there's still some work to be done
to see how that affects specific areas
within within the district but for
example a property in the rural area to
the value of 500k will experience about
431 increase per annum which is about
8.30 a week and the rural area for an
800 000 property it will equate to about
5.48 increase a week if the average was
applied across across those but as we
know there's different differentials
within the within aerating district and
depending on where you are and what you
are and where the costs
originate from will depend on who how
they fall so whilst that's an overall
General it does change between between
areas and at this point we can't we
can't give that information
so if I may continue your worship um
just briefly do we have the opportunity
at this stage to look at the
differentials and the way that that is
put into practice or is that a matter
that we have to look at next in the
long-term plan
through your worship that is an activity
we'll do as part of the long-term plan
as part of the revenue and financing
policy review and the rating the rating
area it's part of what we have proposed
has signaled any last long-term plan
that we wanted to simplify our rate
system and make it easier for everyone
and more transparent for everyone to
understand so there could be some
certainty around what they can expect
going forward so that is a piece of work
that's on the elected members table for
the next six months
Thank you Lorne and thank you counselor
do we have any further questions for
Lorna at this time
uh councilor Stringer and then Council
Reed
are you thanks to worship um got a few
questions here I'd like to put through
so page nine
um item bullet pointed 6.5.6
um a breach in the RFP
um what sort of percentage are we
looking at
your worship that is the funding for
solid waste so our revenue and financing
policy allows us to have between 20 and
39 collected in revenue from user fees
user charges we're currently sitting at
43.7 with what we are proposing for the
increases in fees and charges for
General waste and for reintroduction of
green waste now Council under Section 80
of the local government Council can
resolve to carry on with that
um section section 80 states that
if a decision of a local Authority is
significantly inconsistent with or is
anticipated to have consequences that
will be significantly inconsistent with
any policy adopted by the local
Authority or any plan required by this
act or any other enactment the local
Authority must we're making the decision
clearly identify the inconsistency which
is we're breaching a policy the reasons
for the inconsistency and for this
instance it would be that those who are
using the service should pay for it and
any intention of the local authority to
amend the policy or plan to accommodate
the decision and that will be reviewed
as part of our long-term plan going
forward so there is that available to
the councilors
I might move on and then we'll Circle
back and we'll do one question nature
councilor Reed
my question was actually answered thank
you
um the other thing is I wondered if the
chairs would like to speak to some of
the things that are in this
recommendations
yes um
probably the main one I can see that
I've been
sort of arguing or debating for the last
five years is the increase of debt and
asset upgrades without paying debt off
and this is coming home to roost well
and truly in this budget or this long
annual plan with the um we've been very
lucky for the last two years worth very
very low interest rates and being able
to borrow very cheaply but as everyone
knows with their own mortgage those
interest rates have doubled but we've
got a double whammy our our debtors also
increased significantly in the last year
with the
some of these capital projects finishing
off so we've got more than a double
whammy and that's why there's a five
percent increase just because of the
interest costs
but if you get out you could also argue
looking back you're never able to build
those assets for what we paid for them
now
and we would never got those government
grants so
it's a balancing act and I think we do
have to have that increase passed on
this year
otherwise it's just going to hang over
us and duplicate in the coming years and
um
you've got to phrase up to the fact when
we borrowed a lot of money to get some
good assets and the interest rates have
doubled and we've had an increase in
debt a significant increasing idea but
looking forward we would like to see
that debt level stay where it is or go
lower
to make progress but there's going to be
a hard hard ask at the interest rates of
today
thank you for that councilor uh
you've heard councilor mcfer
just a very short question for your
worship for Monique in regard to the
rates and default on rate payers
um
obviously the situation at the moment is
Council guidelines said we have um
quite heavy costs on householders how
are we looking as a council
through your worship yes the team have
done some analysis on this and we do
recognize that the community is doing a
tough this time last year we had 19
dishonors at the same time this year we
are at up to 98 so the community is
finding a tough and you know we're
trying to work with those people as best
we can to to make it easier for them to
prepay
Dixon
just further to what councilor Gardens
said about death we have had quite a
high wage increases due to the need to
hire staff and retain staff and that's
also put pressure on on the rates along
with a waste Levy that the government's
brought brought in has also added to to
the to the to the rates increase this
year
there's also if we go back a couple of
years when covert struck we had a very
low rate rise and we're still trying to
catch up on that so it's all compounded
into this year and we've ended up with
this very high proposed rate increase
but I'll just leave it there for the
moment
thank you councilor councilor Dixon
okay worship
um with the rates with people not
managing to pay their rates in the huge
increase in that is there any way that
we can keep this rate rise down I know
that you've done an awful lot of work to
try and get it down as far as you can
but going out was at
11.6 percent
is something that I don't feel very
comfortable with because I know families
are struggling and farmers are
struggling at the moment so I'm I'm just
wondering if there's any place we could
still have some movement here apart from
the recommendations today
through your worship and it's entirely
an elected member's hands there are some
costs that we cannot avoid uh audited
fees we've been advised that they're
going up by 37 we're in an ltp year
long-term plan year and that's another
one to one and a half percent of close
to a percent increase in rates so those
are known costs we the other but we have
to balance is what we have promised to
the community as far as the levels of
service goes and we've got to be careful
that if we do take a percentage across
you know we could take a percentage
across all budgets to reduce and ask us
the managers and budget holders to
tighten their belts as but we've got to
be careful and balance it with the level
of service if we change the level of
service then that will require Community
consultation and and we and and some
time and effort and we will miss the
statutory deadline
thank you Lorna and thank you councilor
uh uh we have Council McKenzie Council
McFarland councilor Phillips would you
like a question before we Circle
background uh councilor Phillips and
then councilor mcphail I think you
worship uh it's not so much a question
but just uh a once again I apologize to
Montana right past because
once again we haven't had a review in
the rating and material is going to be
hit once again very hard and
um I've tried the best to try and keep
it down as low as possible and it's at
11.5
six percent
I do apologize but I'm trying to do my
best
in a world that's gone crazy really
thank you councilman Council mcphail
I'm not we're living in a very strange
world at the moment with inflation and
interest rates and
it's just the the costs are there and if
if we want to cut costs to reduce
Services then we've got to realize that
they're going to be reduced services so
that's it's a thing I look at too and I
look at it and think we'll just cut down
the middle and say we're not going to do
these things
but unfortunately we can't do that with
everything we have to do the services
um it's a horrendous rates rise and I
don't like it either but that's the
world we're living in if we go to the
supermarket it's the same so um I just
present offer that's the wages are
another part of that so there's a lot of
things it's a perfect storm we've hit
with the with the debt we've got
and the wage rise and everything it's
all there so I don't agree with it but
that's we just got to face it
unfortunately
thank you councilor councilor McKinsey
it's not really a question I just have a
comment I mean the magical single digit
number it's 9.9 even would be ideal
I honestly don't know what the remedy is
um what was council's did say 10 years
ago
approximately not not exactly just an
approximate figure does anybody have
that
um just just to the gears probably about
under 10 million yeah yeah look I I
totally understand the situation we're
in and it's not a hell of a lot you can
do about it to be perfectly honest but
that magic figure
nine point something would be ideal but
uh what can be done just a comment
really thank you
thank you
thank you councilor and thank you
Council laws for those comments and some
of those questions uh before we do
another lap I would just like to ask a
question
um of Lorne and possibly Jason just
looking at the recycling budgets it says
it goes from 11.56 to 13.67 was that the
same 100 000 figure that we were shown
in the workshop or is there is something
else in there I just didn't realize it
was that much of a jump and percentage
or is there sorry sorry to put you on
the spot
sorry uh through your worship um so
through those those briefings we talked
about
um uh I guess a bit of a staged increase
and so we'd cut back already because of
the fact that we weren't actually able
to get the service into uh play because
we still about to make that decision and
we've got a stand down period before we
can get bins here get them distributed
and then the service and operation so
we've got a
this additional component is really the
um
the option to push it back into the year
one of the long term plan which is why
there's those sort of it's a stagger but
when you combine that together to try
and go as soon as you can you get end up
with it that level so
um like I tried to outline um it was a
cost-saving option for Council to
consider and effectively it results in
the uh whatever it was slightly uh just
under two percent overall rates increase
if we're trying to get that back in play
as soon as we can
yeah so I my recollection from the
workshop was it was one percent for if
we were to do January and two percent if
we were to do from the start of the
financial year but I might got that
wrong so it's two percent from for half
a year that's it great cool thanks for
the clarification right second lap uh
councilor Garden
just just a question through your
worship to Jason
um looking at your table one
6.3.2 on page eight the estimates sort
of have reasonably good jump ups of um
point three point two three point three
three percent point four one percent
point three three percent I'm just
looking at the increase in cost that
we're going to put in for rubbish at the
at the dump will
economics rules rule that when you put
the price up the volume goes down or
we'll wait and see because if the volume
goes down their costs go down and that
economic estimate of 0.33 might come
back to 0.22 so that could make a quite
difference
now through your worship absolutely um
that uh those costs where prior to us
doing anything on the um uh Revenue side
so that was that's just strictly
expenditure and those estimates as sort
of stated in that table were based on uh
Trends to date so showing that effective
either has been a 250k increase in costs
per uh per year over those three years
and then adding then the additional cost
for the waste living into that but there
certainly would be and that's now
budgeted for as the fact that we're
providing additional Revenue to offset
some of those waste living increase
costs
sorry could I just oh yeah go for it
cancel it sorry it's on Theory we
couldn't eerie and hit some casually
if the volume drops down
uh
if the if the volume does reduce
potentially but we've based it so we've
pulled that back and tried to we've
actually sort of tried to Plate over
that off a little bit and saying that
there's
um there will effectively uh be a slight
reduction in the amount of increase that
we've seen in
again the waste side of things is a very
difficult one to to balance and around
volumes and contractual increases which
has been part of the the challenge in
providing accurate costs for this but um
you know we're so it would have to be a
reasonably significant reduction in
volumes to see some savings and it'd be
a little bit reluctant to budget around
that basis but if there were Savings in
there we'd certainly be again looking
through our long-term plan process to
rectify those and and align that where
we can
sorry subsequent to that it would be
ambitious to
um think that there's been any uh
investigation into how much of that
tonnage would be removed if we were to
turn on recycling
just again uh through worship the the
recycling certainly has a uh will have
some benefit but again with the items
that we're talking about in terms of
recycling because we already have glass
out separately you're talking about
plastic cardboard
aluminum you know the Pretty Lights so
in waste is a volume and so we do have
uh an amount of volume there but it's um
yeah it's it's a store as we work
through it and as we get that back
online we'll be able to assess that
impact and again a lot of it uh comes
down to how much we're able to really
drive and educate the change and and
good habits because it's there's still a
big factor in terms of waste around the
amount of contamination that we have so
recycling
um currently I think the Nationwide
standard is that for recycling
um
I think it's 40 of that recycling is
still has some form of contamination in
it so that's where hopefully the
standardized
recycling that's been proposed by the
government along with good quality
communication and education for our
communities can
significantly impact on the amount of
waste that we have going to to landfill
so
there's a lot of work ahead still in
that space cool thank you very much for
that Jason that was that was very clear
sorry counselor Reed
Mr Mayor
um Jason a decrease in the Tipping at
the tip face well that obviously is
going to increase fly tipping as well
because if you can't afford to put it
over you'll be finding other means
so we won't be how do we know that there
is a huge decrease because of people
being proactive or
just generally throwing it where they
feel like it
through your worship yes there is a
chance of having increased fly tipping
I'm sure we will have uh we're willing
to monitor that through uh anticipated
spike in our customer service requests
relating to that however again we're in
mindful we still do have a urban waste
collect curbside collection in place so
that still is there again it's hoping
that this really is really just a
balance out of those that are using the
tip for additional Waste Services are
paying I guess this year and that the
the rate payers aren't just picking that
up for people that reducing waste as
much as they can so it's it really is
around trying to get that balance
between that user pays and their
curbside Collections and in other areas
of recycling EG the stuff that's going
through pakiki and and others at the
moment
councilor mcphail and then Council Dixon
three three worship uh Jason is there
any data out there um with the districts
that have got to work waste minimization
officer uh how effective that is and how
much that drops off your your waste
going over the tip face and the rub the
separation all that stuff that'd be an
interesting thing to know just obviously
off here if there was
um yeah I don't have that um that data
set
um at hand but it's certainly a aspect
that uh
uh elected representatives on wastenet
have been driving home and it's uh
something that we're looking at in terms
of that waste net structure to be able
to actually facilitate that we do have
that joint agreement and we believe that
that it's a waste minimization should be
a component of that and that we can
um it needs to be something that is
really distributed across the region and
it's becoming more and more evident that
we need to have that
um
constant engagement with particularly
with the changes that are coming
from the government they've been
indicated to be legislated over the the
next sort of 12 to 18 months as I
understand it and so there will be a
real need to have that support but um
yeah this you know at this varying
levels and varying various places
depending on
um again how much you resource any level
of service and so if you have
um uh other
uh districts do have the ability to have
bigger and larger resources in terms of
their Solid Waste areas and possibly
seeing better results but that's really
only uh speculative at this stage
there's a number of different factors
that contribute to that in terms of the
types of services you provide
um matched up with then how active you
are in terms of your community and the
buy-in of community into those services
thank you
thank you thank you Jason and thank you
councilor councilor Dixon and then
Council
three worship
um just Jason I'm wondering you spoke
about government legislation
is the government doing anything to
assist waste minimization is in
manufactured waste because that comes
down and then that's for the consumer
that has to pay for the dispose of it so
is there any movement there with
government
uh three worship yes your series
um so uh termed product stewardship
um is a key work stream now for
government around
um around solid waste and I guess the
the move to first step in that is the
move to standardized
um curbside recycling indicating what
um
material was uh considered to be
acceptable in terms of recycling that
will certainly help and give an
indication to um both importers and
businesses around what what we should
where we should be focusing
um and but there's a yeah it's a
reasonably complex process but it
certainly is being worked on and was
part of a
the wise conference discussion um last
week in Hamilton and there is certainly
some stuff happening in that space that
will then be flowing through and certain
businesses will be we're already
starting to see some
legislation come through around
different types of and forms of
packaging and so there's that will only
increase is as the government's desire
to get things out of uh landfill and
into either reuse or recycle becomes a
priority
um across across New Zealand
I think it counselor counts councilor
Stringer then hover
oh yeah it's through your worship I'm
going to give Jason a bit of a break
speaking here I want to look at
Personnel costs uh items 7.3
um previously the council has been using
the library so there's already been some
Associated claiming costs worth it
um how much more has it changed and are
we or do we have enough fees on the
rooms that we're renting out to cover
any Clan costs or damage costs Etc going
forward
through your worship it's very early
days with the new community rooms and we
are learning with each booking we've got
initial indications are that FES may be
pitched too low and that we could
revisit that so if elected members wish
us to do that we can we can look at that
with regards to library cleaning
um previously it was a smaller footprint
and it was contracted out with it coming
on site here we have got our own
internal cleaner that we're using so yes
we're saving some money and contract
fees but the footprint and the type of
materials that have used for example the
carpet with the undulations make it much
more challenging to clean fingerprint
sunglass on glass stairwells and stuff
are all all items that take extra time
and I know it sounds small and pedantic
but it is the things that take extra
time so we have had it spec by
professional cleaners on how long it
should take also being a public facility
you need to make sure that there's
certain levels you maintain around to
cleaning of toilets and Public public
spaces so
we have had expect the previously there
were a staff I think two staff with the
previous James Wing when that
was closed for
refurbishment and stuff moving in those
staff we know are no longer employed by
the council so it's a cost that was
taken out around that cover time and now
needs to be put back in
thank you
Council Heather I'm wondering if I'm
jumping the gun have you finished taking
questions
have we finished taking questions uh
Council Dixon and Council streamer would
say otherwise Council Dixon you're up
thank you wish it
um I'm just wondering I know there will
be a cost to the review is that already
in our budget or not
today
through your worship as the cost only
came through on the last week it is not
in the 11.56 so will need to be found
that as an additional 0.65 on rates and
would take it to 12.121 so we would need
to find savings elsewhere to cover that
if we want to keep the increase down but
it is a now is now a known cost and we
should include it so that we don't end
up with cash flow problems down the road
seems very high cost I might add as well
but we can discuss it later
yes it can be further discussed when
it's when it's finalized and that item
is Revisited cancer Stringer
hey thanks to worship through you page
12 item 8.6
um a common approach utilized by
councils and these types of
circumstances is to not to fully fund
appreciation what are the options
obviously that indicates these other
options there to use and how would they
affect us
at the moment we have proposed a 30
unfunded three Waters renewals so we've
effectively said we will keep it to the
long-term plan renewals program and not
not fully fund every anything else so
for me that is a good option but it's
not sustainable long term the only other
assets where I could see Council doing
that in the short term and I do have
size short term is both the
administration building and the library
because they're both very new assets
that have just come on stream so they'll
have 50-year lives and to not fully fund
the depreciation in the first couple of
years would would probably would be okay
oh sorry sorry what sort of saving would
that I'm finding that depreciation for
two years or for it for the two building
spring
so you wish it would depend on what
percentage you used uh for for both
buildings the annual depreciation would
be around about 120 000 you would still
want to fund some of that so you might
gain a half a percent uh along the way
counselor string of the encounter
guardine
thanks to worship um just following up
on that then would we have to include in
the long-term plan that we
um
reaccumulate that funding on a load of
date just to make up for it
for your issue yes you would you would
want to look to do that long term
thank you
it would probably affect air lowering
the debt in those two areas too would it
and that's the long-term planners of
trying to get the debt down to make some
savings
do we think it's fair to potentially ask
the CFO to provide us with what maybe 50
looks like at least then we can discuss
it at a prior day set doable
what does 50 look like for us about
three zero point three percent
after that 0.25
uh three Euro ship uh 50 would probably
in a rough rough calculation I'm not
good at doing rough calculations on the
spot you'd possibly get close to 0.7
of a percent for the two buildings
wait counselors Ponder on that for a
second
while you're pondering kinoy just so
it's a really interesting discussion
listening to you contemplating the
challenges between being a good asset
manager and being a good Financial
Manager or not
and councilor Garden has actually picked
up the point and Council Stringer that
you're actually potentially just putting
this issue onto a council and yourself
next year or the year after or the year
after that the common terminology
and our speakers kicking the can down
the road
um but you're kicking the can down your
road that you're gonna have to pick up
again next year
I think it's uh thank you for that Rex I
I think it's an interesting challenge
that we have as counselors given the
um state of the economy right now and
the the cost of living crisis is how
much can we
save that hurt of our ratepayers and
we're paying for that kicking the can
down the road of the two point something
percent rate rise over covert when we
thought that was that was the worst it
was going to be
um so and that this council is not
unique in that at all that happened
across the board with with zero zero
percent rate increases and we're seeing
the same up north where they're having
to do 18
rate increases because of those
decisions that they made so
yeah not an easy time but
we push on do we have any further
questions for lornay
or any of those
um stuff that matter
should we get into the recommendations
then
I just make a a general comment before
we look at the specific recommendations
and you'll pick it up from if I may
um and you'll pick it up from the
questions that I asked and I am very
concerned with the rating structure that
we have here in Gore
I don't believe it is Equitable I don't
believe it's fear and
um
what it means is that what we're faced
with at present particularly when it
comes to a number of groups that have
come before us asking for funding we're
having to say not because of a whole
combination of things and I think
there's some groups out there that are
getting funding from Council in terms of
applying for Grants
Etc many of which don't need it and more
worthy groups are missing out and
there's one that's referred to later in
the agenda that we can't fund at this
time
interestingly I have rural people
telling me it's not fair on the rural
people and I have Urban people telling
me that they're taking too much of of
the can but the structure that we've got
has been around for many years and and
an answer to my question it's only
something that we can address in the
long-term plan so I really want to
assure the public that myself and and
having talked to a number of other
counselors are going to be looking that
very in some detail in terms of moving
forward with the long-term plan in the
next six months
I just wanted to also just make a a
brief comment in terms of waste and I
know it's one of the specific
motions that are there
um elected representatives from the
three territorial authorities
work together on an organization called
wastenet and that looks at the waste
collection over the whole region and I'm
chair of that organization and now
meeting two weeks ago was a public
meeting for the first time and and it
was broadcast on on the council's
communication system and people could
watch it what is clearly coming out in
the waste sector is that the government
is driving up the costs of waste
disposal and that's impacting on our
ratepayers as well and we don't have any
choice other than to pay it at this time
but waste net is trying to look at a
fairer approach across the whole region
and one of the things that had been put
forward by staff was in relation to a
waste minimization officer and waste
neck is resolved to look at the
possibility of actually directly paying
for minimization officers in each other
Council so that was something that was
able to come out of the budget and
possibly save us one percent or more
of more importance I think to The Wider
Community is that during the last
election a key issue that came up was
recycling
and I'm disappointed that we can't
proceed with the recycling at this stage
just because of the cost that's involved
but on the other hand
we're looking at working together as a
whole region in a way that might
actually give us some Savings
in the long term so
deferring that until next year is
something that's quite
sensible so they're just the general
things I wanted to say at this stage
thank you
thank you councilor um I thought I'd
just clarify that those decisions
haven't been made yet if there's your
opinions
um and and we'll see how each of these
recommendations go but those sorts are
differently recorded
counselor mix now just before we go to
recommendations I just want to make one
more comment
just to get the right rise down because
I've I've talked uh at length with
lornay about depreciation and other
levers we can pull and the effect on
them but
one thing I like just as a a blanket
thing because I've also talked about
targeting various departments and trying
to get savings out of there but if we
just took the 11.56 and blanket said
we're going to go for 10.56 to 1 off and
just asked the senior management team
over the next 12 to try and reduce costs
that would be about 200 000 over a
budget of about 26 27 million it's it's
not a big figure but it was just just
one suggestion they'll just like
if anyone wants to comment on that from
the management
settings skills you know um
your
suggestion has been considered already
by staff
and in my experience in Long career and
local government
um budgeting on
can you see if you can do it approach
generally ends and tears
and generally will pick have to be
picked up the following year because we
haven't been able to achieve it so it's
similar to kicking the can down the road
if it's going to happen we need to plan
for it to happen not to just come out
now and say can you take one percent out
and we need to actually be able to show
you that that one percent is out we
haven't done that and we haven't been
able to do that and I would just be
reluctant to
go down a path where where we're at the
whim of trying something but I actually
haven't planned to do it because that's
not what going through an annual plan
process is about
um that's all I would say in terms of
that like we we have as a staff as not
just as a senior leadership team but
also our activity managers themselves
have been asked to do that and actually
when we've gone into some of those
budgets
they're working on budgets or contracts
that are increasing and we're asking
them to take money out of them and so
the contractor rates have actually
increased so all we're doing is passing
those on so it's a really difficult type
rope that everyone's walking at the
moment but appreciate
um the the query to try and assist us
I just had to throw that question
sorry just on that point and I
appreciate that lornay and the team have
been as we talked about looking into the
cushions see if there's any pennies in
there
um I guess a
is there a potential report even if it
comes out that there's going to be a
change level of service of what that one
percent would look like even if it's not
realistic so that we can look it and go
oh like in terms of more of an education
piece would that be quite a lot more
work
um to get that like if that thinking's
already been done just a little bit more
of actually I know we talked about
mowing the grass and things like that
what that actually means and
um is that too much to ah I know we're
on a tight tight time frame
um I just just might help elected
members out of where that that one
percent what they would look like
um and and how tough that would be
to be feared alone I end to like I say
not just the senior leadership team but
the activity managers
we've rung it that dry that I I just
think for the last four weeks or for the
next four weeks to try and I mean we can
do that and bring something back for the
adoption of the annual plan report but
it might not be any different
um and uh earring on the side of caution
my advice would be
that's a that's a long-term plan
discussion that really allows us to to
peel everything back
um and have the levels of service
discussion that need to be had which
then put those costs against it
to try and do that in two weeks
after we've already been trying to do it
in the last month or so I think we is is
not necessarily a good use of time sorry
you worship but
I think we have to make sure that you
appreciate and understand that that's
that's certainly a just the starting
point for a long-term plan discussion
and we're in the midst of a long-term
plan to starting the starting in the
midst of a long-term plan 24 34 and now
and that's when the hard work of peeling
that back actually happens so short term
versus long term I urge you to really
get you to think further in that fork in
the road to be be in a conversation for
the long-term plan not in the next two
weeks
yeah I guess where my thinking was if we
can scoop up that month's worth of back
and forth and if it can be somehow put
into presentable form just so we can see
that that one percent is going to be
really hard to get but um yeah totally
appreciate the amount of effort that
that would bring uh councilor guardian
and then Council mcfarl
he's not agree with Rex you know this is
a question for the long-term plan and
this is where people need to be
realistic going into long-term plan as
well our priorities lie and um Genesis
saving a few dollars now is it's going
to be a bigger question as doing in the
long-term plan it's where you do it and
you look at the whole picture
the other Big Challenge we have of
course is the three Waters and they're
going out in two 18 months or whether it
actually goes out it can take a lump of
debt out of our system but it will still
hurt the town people
um because they'll have a three Waters
bill as well as the council Bill and our
overheads will go up so we've got some
big challenges going forward and the
long-term planning is really we should
look at those plans yeah
take your counselor well said Council
mcfarl uh yes I I agree I think the key
thing I'm thinking about there's not a
household on any District that hasn't
had to cut their budget
day-to-day stuff so as long as people
realize that we're actually trying to
look at what we can save
where we can save it and try and do the
services because if we don't mow The
Lawns you know there's things like that
but everybody's in the same situation
for the council the household so it's a
it's a situation we've got to work
through so I recognize it but it sounds
like the long-term plan is a way to do
it and look to the Future for that as
far as it goes if you worship
thank you councilor also also well said
cancel the reading and then I think we
might start getting into these
recommendations thank you it's just a
comment Mr me um just a reminding rate
payers that while this sounds horribly
excessive we do have a five percent cap
and we're very rarely gone over that
um but the other thing to be reminded
about too is that the rates rebate
scheme provided by the government
actually is quite
um
quite a good opportunity for some
families not just pensioners or anybody
else but some P all of those people that
think they could be affected to apply
for that that's on the council website
and every year the government actually
lifts that payment so why you may not
have qualified last year you may well
Supply qualify this year so just a
reminder
thank you counselor
any further comments before we get into
the recommendation
could we can we get the uh just the
receiving the report out the way first
um do we have a counselor who's willing
to remove that councilor Phillips and a
seconder councilor guard on I will let
Council Stringer speak to that if you
would like
we worship
um yeah just that the recommendations
that I would like to make a change to
item L
um it currently States and that the
council resolves to not consult on the
2023-24 annual plan I'd like to change
it to and that the council resolves to
not formally consult
um because there are still processes
that I think we can use that people can
have their own pots via online and
talking to us as well going forward it
just sort of doesn't shut everyone out
of the the process thank you
yes uh good point there councilor all
right I come towards that and we'll get
to that at the end of the list
so the motion on the table is that the
report we receives
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
recommendation B do we have a mover for
that Council Havel
what would you what direction would you
like to go on
there's there's approval to not approve
so I'll ask the direction on each of
these for the movement
so just for those who didn't hit on the
microphone it is that the council
approve the deferral of the introduction
of the three bin curbside collection
until the 1st of July 2024 do we have a
seconder
uh oh that was close I'm going to
counselor mcfail on that one
uh do we have any discussion I will
start off with those in favor
and those against
um which will be me I campaigned on
having curbside recycling uh at the
first of July 2023 I still stand by that
I I know that it's a that it's a rate
increase of almost two percent but I
think the the only way you can get
started the earlier the community learns
how to use recycling we can have that
Pro program uh rolling people can learn
how to use Recycling and they can
recycle and it'll be better for our
planets and the environment but that is
just my opinion
um councilor Dixon thank you worship I'd
just like to add that people can
actually recycle themselves where
there's a there's a curb collection or
not there's places you can put your
bottles tins cardboard paper and those
sorts of things so
um I'd like to see that to continue
thank you Council and it goes without
saying that the the amazing work that
the pikiki lions are doing in the space
for commercial my opinion is that it is
our responsibility to do it to a
curbside but I respect the opinions of
all the other councilors
do we have any further discussion on
this recommendation
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against could I please be recorded
as against
the motion is carried thank you
counselors
uh number number c let us see uh do we
have a mover for that recommendation
uh councilor Reed and what direction was
that
so just for the microphone again uh that
the council approved uh sorry it's away
with the fear is
um that the council does approve the
increase to fees and charges by 30 at
the transfer station excluding green
waste
thank you councilor and a secondary
thank you councilor mcphail
uh do we have anyone for the affirmative
I would like to comment
and against
no discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
and I and against the motion is carried
D do I have a mover for d
uh councilor mechanel and which way are
you going on this one
approve so the council approve the Tori
to reintroduce a charge for all green
waste over 100 kilos in weights to have
a seconder
councilor Stringer
do I have any conversation for the
affirmative
and against
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
I and against the motion is carried
on to E do I have a mover for E
councilor over which way would you like
to go
turning on the mic uh that the council
approve a communication officer role as
funded for the nine month 2023-24 and
fully funded thereafter
thank you councilor and a seconder
councilor Stringer
do we have anyone for the affirmative
and the negative
I just had a question sorry the
11.56 thing is what we're looking at did
that include the communications officer
at this stage thank you
now for the uh Council Val
is the Mover I'd just like to say that
the level of communications both into
and out of this building over the last
couple of years has increased
tremendously and it falls basically on
the shoulders of one staff member at
present so
um employing a further person in that
role is essential
thank you for that counselor
I'll put the motion although in favor
please say aye I and against the motion
is carried
motion if
recommendation if counselor Reed
I would like to move that Council does
approve the part-time assistant
facilities officer for the exactly the
same reasons that councilor Havel has
just mentioned about the communications
officer
thank you councilor and a seconder
uh councilor Dixon and just Clarity
again that was included and yep thank
you very much do we have anything for
the affirmative
the negatives
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye aye and against
the motion is carried
recommendation G counselor guard iron
Mike Mike
did the council approve uh 30 unfunded
depreciation for the three Waters
activity
and councilor McDonald to second that
do we have any conversation for the
affirmative
the negative
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against
motion is carried
recommendation h
I do we need to resolve it today I
recognize that we had a conversation
around the the two buildings is that a
thick recommendation H still on there no
okay
we have a mover for that
yeah I'll move uh councilor McDonald and
a secondary
Council Stringer
I see a couple of questionable looks on
that recommendation do you mind just
clarifying it thanks a lot
uh three you worship this is
um to realign air 22 23 actuals to
annual plan and our annual plan we had
uh taken into account a revaluation of
22.2 million the real uh the actual
revaluation came through at 66.6 million
so in our annual plan we have budgeted a
third of the increase for depreciation
and what what staff are proposing is
that we stick to that budget rather than
the actual depreciation on the increase
of 66.6 million because we have budgeted
the renewals program on that on the
increase of 22.2 million so we're just
seeking uh approval from Council to to
stick to the budget rather than the
increase
that seemed clear to everyone cleared it
up for me so that's good
uh so we have them over in a second uh
do we have uh for the FM uh we don't
have affirmative a negative really on
this one so I will just put the motion
all in favor please say aye
and against motion is carried
recommendation I do we have a mover uh
councilor Phillips in the direction
thank you where is it um I'd like to
move that uh we do not approve the grant
at this time
thank you councilor and a second note
Council councilor read
um could I just make a comment
um I'd know that I moved that initially
and um given the times unfortunately I
feel we have to backtrack it's nice to
have it's not a need and I hope that we
can look at that possibly in their
annual plan or through the long-term
plan sorry or through the grants
committee possibly as well
thank you councilor councilman trial
history worship uh I was obviously
involved in
um I think it was the second door
involved in that uh approval when I went
through the community Wellness Wellness
committee
um and I concur with
um councilor reads commentary there and
this is a victim of obviously where we
are this is one of these things that uh
when you look at it the person providing
a great great service with a lot of
inspiration and a lot of passion for
youth in the community and sadly it's
going to be one that Miss out and
probably from our point of view as a
council as a counselor I'm hoping that
there's probably some other uh funding
groups or maybe someone in the community
could actually pick up on that so but uh
sadly it's uh I have to bet they're not
approving today
thank you councilor and it is the
unfortunate state of uh of the economy
and the cost of living crisis that some
of these grants unfortunately that the
council doesn't have the resources to
pay for these at this time which is it's
very sad um Council Dixon
we worship I'd just like to say too that
I'm very disappointed that we had to
turn this down because of the economic
climate that we're in
um
I actually agree with councilor Reed and
counseling mcphail I'd like to see this
come through the grants committee and be
considered in the long-term plan but
it's very hard to prioritize when some
of these grants have already been
ratified so I'm sure it would have been
high up there in receiving a grant
because of this really assists the youth
in Gore so it's disappointing that
that we didn't have the grants committee
and and be able to prioritize some of
the grants but look at it next time
around
thank you
thank you councilor uh councilor
mcdonell uh just this group may be able
to approach uh approach someone like
lions and rotary and see if they could
fund this for a short time
thank you councilor if there's no
further comment I will put the motion
all those in favor please say aye
I and against the motion is carried
uh recommendation J
councilor Phillips glad to move uh
recommendation Jay and it's full you
work sure
to approve or to non-approved sorry to
approve
thank you councilor and a seconder
councilor mechanel
and do we have any conversation for the
affirmative
the negative the feminine Council
addiction negative the negative consider
um I just believe that this is a nice to
hear not a a real need at this time so I
will be voting against this
thank you councilor
um I guess Council Hill
may I ask
um
how much the beautification fund gets
each year present and when was the last
time that it was reviewed
councilor Phillips
yep councilor Phillips
uh thank you uh I believe it would have
started in its conception of the
material community board in
93 96 somewhere around there uh it sits
it sits at twenty thousand per annum
hasn't increased since then uh hence why
the community board have got a few
projects on board coming up a few ideas
in the long term and their long-term
plan as such
and we believe that a small increase is
definitely required to continue on with
the projects that they're doing
and if you look at the money that's
spent with in within that time
you know the project projects that it's
gone to have all been beneficial for the
whole Community not only just the
material District but also the full
District
is the pump track is one of those
um venues that people go to
thank you councilor councilor Reed thank
you Mr
um I was wondering how much actually is
in the fund currently
be one question
um currently there was it was sitting
around the 100 plus thousand but it was
spent up on buying the Green Space land
for the railway station
so that was the last big spinach on it
right so it's down to about 27 000
something
and my other question would be
um what percentage of um input would air
parks and Reserve Department have as far
as material beautification
sorry counselor I'd imagine that it
touched the discretion of the mataida
community board but the parks and
reserves manager does attend those
meetings very frequently so they they
quite often have conversation on
spending that fun but councilor Phillips
did you want to add oh thank you yeah no
the the whole projects are gone through
uh rigorously through the council as and
such and also the staff who combined
their ideas
for what we consider to be
projects that are beneficial you know
like the the money that's spent is is
definitely going into the beautification
the last
um big spend was in the main street in
Bridge Street
and then after that was the
Green Space required for the railway
station
even though the railway station hasn't
gone ahead the Green Space has been
acquired by the board which means that
it can
create a better Park in there at Queen's
Park
it just didn't further counselor Aid um
as you know elected members don't have
any delegations so the community would
all of their projects actually have to
come back through the staff
um
system to for sign off and for for
approval for payments Etc so it's done
that way as a wicket just as a point of
clarification from reading this um
recommendation correctly in four years
time this beautification fund will have
thirty thousand dollars going into it
annually is that correct
three worship yes that's that's the
that's the intention
I I guess this point I wanted to raise
and I'm open to and I just wanted to
throw it out there is given that we're
entering long-term plan
um conversations do we want to lock
ourselves into this 2500 sum for the
next
four years or is it something that we
agree to this annual plan and then
re-look at in the long term plan um and
it might pan out the same but it could
be a different number too uh councilor
Bell
I'd just like to clarify the statement
you made in terms of 2500 per year the
way it's written it'll be 2500 this year
5000 next year seven and a half the year
after and ten after that
but I think your point is well made in
terms of four years out
I would be
yeah I would begin to move a amendment
to that recommendation
um that the recommendation is to approve
but it's just for the 2500 for this
annual plan
I'm happy to move that do we have a
second to counselor guard on
do we have any comment around the
amendment itself
uh councilor Stringer
thanks to worship um as long as it is
brought forward in the long-term plan
that there is something set out Way
Forward for um materials funding
yes I think Rex has just written that
down so that'll definitely be part of
the discussion uh councilor Phillips
I think you worship no no I'm extremely
disappointed that we've got this to that
today to have a discussion
we came to a compromise
and when I asked them or for approval of
ten thousand and I believe that the
material ratepayer
would understand what we're trying to
achieve here even though it is a
percentage you're on the right
um
and for us now to say no we're not going
to do this and then go back to the
long-term plan and I think I think
yeah I just like to express my
disappointment
thank you councilor councilor Garden
and probably with the amendment we're
not saying no we're just saying that
we're going to review it at the
long-term plan
yes counselor so it's approving the 2500
here today but then promising to discuss
it as part of the long-term plan Council
Havel I'd like to flag for counselors
that if this motion is the amended
motion is lost I would further move that
it be 2 500 this year and five thousand
dollars next year just because of the
time leap that we're facing to get
things done
is there any further discussion on that
amendment in particular
a point of order uh the amendment that
you take a vote on first is just keeping
it 2 000 for this year thank you Council
that's that's what I was asking for yeah
yeah any further discussion on the
current amendments on the table but
thank you for noting that if that it is
too
um not succeed
we will put that to a vote all those in
favor please say aye aye
and against
okay show of hands so for the
affirmative
one two three four five six and for the
negative
one two three four five
so sorry uh I voted four
so the motion is carried
so now the recommendation on uh sorry
the motion on the table is that the
Council approve the Matilda
beautification fund to be increased by
two thousand five hundred for this
annual plan
and for it to be discussed in the long
term plan but probably doesn't need to
be part of the recommendation
do we have any further conversation on
that motion
no I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
aye
and against
councilor Phillips would you like that
recorded
and everyone else is fine the motion has
been carried thank you counselors
recommendation k
do I have a mover
uh councilor Reed
for against I'd like to move that the
council approved the increase in the
Grant and donation to the matawara
bowling club for their voluntary work at
the Matera collection part
thank you councilor and a secondary
councilor Phillips
second councilor Phillips and uh did we
have discussion for the affirmative
service um I'd like to raise a point of
order and in terms of that motion it is
not specific
it does not refer to a particular amount
of money and I don't think the council
can pass it in its present form
and this one of order is denied there is
clarification and uh point a page
13.11.2 that says it's 3460 per annum
would you like it in the recommendation
uh it needs to be in the recommendation
to have certainty absolutely are you
happy to make that slight change
councilor read
yep okay that will be added did we get
that Susan just just I'd also says a
double negative on the end of the end of
the report it's actually not worded all
right
at the end it says is not approved
three three words need deleted
so for clarification it is that the
council approve an increase in the grant
slash donation
of
3460 per annum
to the matoda bowling club for their
voluntary work at the matoda collection
point we're happy with that councilor
Reed
thank you counselor uh councilor Dixon
clarify per annum is this are we not
going to review this and will it not
come up
and the long-term plan
uh so that that means it will be
recurring so it'll be that 3460 every
year from this point forward so it won't
go up up there every year that will be
the new figure that they they get paid
so they get paid half there every year
currently they'll now get double that
every year
can this be reviewed absolutely yeah
yeah that's what I was asking really and
for the long-term plan everything it's
in the long-term plan yes
is another point of order and arising
from that where a motion of counsel has
passed by understanding of standing
orders is that it then takes a 75 vote
of council to change it
and I do note that the increase while
it's only 0.02 percent has not been
provided for and the rates increase
the point of order to more a comment
the
uh is it a comment
I'll I'll leave it to you to judge there
I can't make a decision on the point of
order sorry so
um I'll just I'll just deny and and
accept the comment
um
uh I'm not too sure
just just some clarification
um
from Rick's there that at 11.3 it does
State this is not included as a price
rate so it will go from 11.56 up to
11.58
so it is that that to 0.02 rate increase
any further discussion on this one here
good
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say I I and against
councilor hovel would you like that
recorded
councilor Dixon who's like that recorded
as well
and the motion is carried thank you
councilors
just before oh we'll do the consultation
one and then I've got another two here
uh so the the so recommendation L do I
have a mover
for that
do you want to move it cancel the
Stringer considering you made the change
yet happy to do that so it reads uh and
that the council resolves to not
formally consult on the 2023-2024 annual
plan
uh seconded by councilor McDonald I just
wanted to make a comment for the public
as a point of clarification
um the reason why we don't necessarily
have to consult on this annual plan is
because it the levels of service are
still within that that was consulted as
part of the long-term plan so there's
not a there's not a major variance
between what we're providing as a
council that we consulted on that well
the previous Council Consultants on the
long term plan compared to this annual
plan
uh but we will be Consulting on the
long-term plan um it is it is a
necessity councilor Dixon
could I just ask that you explained what
um it means not to consult and and um
how the public members of the public
would do that is it through email
what Avenue is there for that to happen
I'm sure members of the public are
welcome to give us feedback it's it says
councilor Stringer um noted it's not
formal consultation so it's not a formal
process but I would imagine that rate
payers will be very vocal in telling us
what they think about the rate increase
I would expect so
um any changes they they would like to
see um and I'm sure that will come
through our Communications Department
and and yeah but it won't be a formal
process as possible but what will we do
with that if it's not a formal process
if people do I'll leave it to rexton can
I back up
um his Worship in in his explanation of
formal consultation as we're we're not
formally consulting which means we're
not going up to formally ask submissions
basically or for submissions to then
deliberate on and then if you make a
decision but as worshipers has mentioned
the opportunity and one of the reasons
why we wanted to put make sure that this
draft annual plan was put in front of
the public today to your debate
discussion and so on
um was then to provide the opportunity
for them to be able to come back to you
informally talking to your email and
whatever you wish for you to hear
because this is going to come back up to
you at a at a at a meeting scheduled for
the 27th of June when you will formally
adopt your annual plan
the the the thing that I would encourage
with any of the feedback that you
receive between now and then that needs
to be brought to the table now if you
receive that feedback in the next couple
of weeks I really encourage you to feed
that through to Lorne so that if there
is any significant
amendments or changes that come through
as a result of that feedback she's been
able to provide the time to be able to
do those workings
so you're not formally adopting your
annual plan until the 27th of June but
there is a period between now and
certainly in the next couple of weeks
for any public feedback to then be fed
through you to and I'm sure we'll get
feedback as at a staff level as well
that I think is the probably the
critical point councilor Dixon in terms
of of how it's able to be taken on board
thank you for that Rex I think you sum
it up a lot clearer than I did uh
uh we have a mover and we had a seconder
uh is there any further conversation
I will put that motion all those in
favor please say aye
aye and against the motion is carried
now I've got two more here do we want to
formally resolve these I think I think
we should so that the first first one I
have written down uh is to ask the uh as
a to ask lornay um to provide a report
or feedback around not depreciating 50
of the two new buildings
uh is it a fair recommendation
so it's part of that that next
conversation yeah yeah it'll it'll come
back
do we need as a formal resolution are
you comfortable carrying that out
uncomfortable because I mean lorno's
understands that we can incorporate that
into a cover report for you to consider
as part of the final adoption of the
final annual plan
cool I will leave leave those and we
will move on oh the other one was just
around the the comment that councilor
McDonald made around whether we could
get that one month worth of working into
some sort of formalized um but I'll
leave that up to the interpretation of
staff for their cover report
I'll share it with with counselors um so
it's not my own decision um but Rex was
just noting um the 130 000 that uh
councilor Reed commented on at the start
oh sorry Council addiction at the start
sorry
um whether we should add that to uh this
current annual plan draft
um so that we have a more realistic uh
percentage to put out there
um or given that the item was tabled
earlier in the in the meeting
um whether we wait until we have a
finalized number of of those costings
before we add it into the the annual
plan
counselor ah sorry not counselor Rick
sorry
um
again is was raised at the start of the
discussion
um and I think Lorne raised it that that
there's a well it's an estimate cost
um that has been proposed which
um with a with you laying that item on
the table will probably now guarantee
that it will be a new Financial year
project
um so it won't be you know so there's
two ways that you can do it I mean it
certainly flagged that you intend to
undertake an independent review
and that you've been given an estimated
cost in the vicinity of of
um that 100 to 130k
you can factor a review cost into your
annual plan workings and that can go in
there that can be included we it's
really well in some direction it's if
you want to add that have that added
into the annual plan final annual plan
which you'll adopt on the 27th of June
or if you want to deal with it
separately in the New York Financial
year in which as is on the table today
it would come up as an unbudgeted
expenditure item no matter which way
you've still got to make it decision
you either make the decision and
incorporate it into your annual plan now
which then provides the public with the
real rate increase before I can put it
as blunt as that versus you approve or
you look to adopt your annual plan
without it in knowing that it is going
to be a cost that is going to need to be
added into your operations next
financial year
it was really just getting some
direction Lorna do you have anything
further from your perspective from a
finance out of Finance Management
perspective and for best practice Yeah
through your worship if it's not
included in the annual plan then it
becomes unbudgeted and then and Pace on
cash flow so from a cash flow
perspective I would much rather have an
allowance in there whether it's for the
130 or a lesser figure we need to have
something in there because then it's
only going to have to be recouped from
rate payers in the year following and
the long-term plan to catch it up
we can
um
we can come back to you with the on the
27th of June meeting
um with at a commentary around what
we've done with that and that will be
when the decision is made but I just
wanted to flag it
um we don't you know and I think I'm
getting the general General feel of
where we'll land it but it will
certainly be landed for that 27th of
June meeting in which you will make the
decision in the public will be aware of
that decision at that time which I swear
thank you
so we're leaving it for the dinner plan
discussion okay cool
cool listen any further comment we will
move on to the last item on this meeting
agenda
thank you councilors item number six
proposed fees and charges for the
2023-224 year uh Lorne would you like to
speak on this ice model
through your worship
um I will take the item as as read but
happy to take questions and suggestions
from elected members on directions if
we've got the levels right or not or
whether they want to season for the
changes
thank you lornay any questions from
counselors
councilor Dixon I've got
um a number of queries
one is the pokerail symmetry
I I note that it's got a family burial
plot it's two thousand dollars now is
set
as a family does that mean a sign you
may not be able to answer this Lorna
it's probably a case question but
um
yeah the other plots that I know
elsewhere and other symmetries are a
thousand dollars
but the pokerail cemetery family burial
plot is two thousand dollars
so I'm just wondering if that side by
side or
what that actually means it's just a
point of clarification really
yeah through three worship I'll need to
clarify that with the parks manager and
come back thank you
um the building consents the mbie brands
and accreditation lives
on page 27
it's um
a dollar for every thousand dollars is
is that over and above
the building consent as well so if you
have a 16 or a 600k building you're
paying 18K in extra fees for these
three organizations page 27
three oceans I believe that is the case
but again we can clarify that with the
building control manager
okay
um
the Aquatic Center
just it's a charge for over 65s
it says
um
five dollars over 65 dollars
but 80 year olds are free but is that
only for annual subscriptions do we know
them
or is that a like the one-off charge
it's not on here
page um if my memory excuse me correctly
I believe it was a resolution passed by
Council a while back that over 80s it
was along with the free parking for over
80s as well I think yes I understand
that but it's not in the um
it's not in the in the schedule here
you've just got over 60s five dollars
three three Russia we can add that in
for clarification to say that over eight
years are free that would be good
um
last one I think resource consents
um 850 all land use consent eight fifty
dollars to 1580 which is a huge increase
in the Heritage orders uh three um
thousand to five thousand notified
uh no sorry 3K to five thousand K
notified is jumped from 750 to 14 30.
it's quite a huge increase is that the
actual costs
three worship this is based on actual
cost but it also relates to the deposits
so in the past deposits have been quite
low uh and and people when they've come
back to get the full the invoice have
been surprised by the additional amount
so this is a Readjustment of those
deposits to better reflect true time
costs uh the staff have done some work
in the background to show what the real
costs are and trying to reflect them
into into the charges thank you and last
one
just wondering about mobile Traders
from um
if they're trading one day to one month
it's just 25 dollars
they pay no rates no power and they're
in competition with other retailers is
that a fair charge or should that be
maybe 25 for a week and after that
they're charged further
through your worship there are bylaws in
place to that regulate how close they
can be to other businesses situated
established businesses that provide the
same products so there is a certain
amount of distance that they have to be
from those before they can trade I can
go back to the regulatory manager and
ask if that is a that is a fear that can
be revised
thank you
thank you Council for all those
questions it was great uh councilor
Stringer
oh yeah thanks to worship um look this
one's a bit of a tongue cheek it's just
how things are worded in here page 28
cemeteries we've got a single burial
plot 2.7 by 1.2 with right to purchase
next to joining plot at time of death
um I just want to ask to see how many um
deed people have taken up the offer of
buying the adjoining plot
I'm unsure
thank you councilor did you have any
other questions no
can I just ask uh lornay what just out
of curiosity what was kind of the the
methodology between some of these
increases was it around inflation or was
it just looked at line by line and kind
of a or was it other councils I just add
up yeah curiosity so um my team went out
and talked to the individual managers to
talk about what what the real costs were
and the areas so it was up to the budget
holders and the managers in those areas
too so some of the disc combination of
looking at our neighbors so again the
Aquatic Center looked at their neighbors
to say you know air FES are quite and
charges are quite low in comparison to
our neighbors
with building a lot of theirs was was in
relation to the electronic filing fee
which was causing some confusion so
rather than have a separate electronic
filing fee they've built it into the
charges resource consents was based on
actual time
and the waste as we've discussed
previously in the previous item we've
applied a 30 charge the general waste
and again I think three Waters and I've
got three water staff there they'll be
able to help me out on this I believe it
was looking at actuals and and also
applying a percentage across across the
across the board so there's a few again
it's it's tailored for what the activity
is is experiencing at the time but there
is you know if counselors want us to
look at some of those charges that we
haven't quite got right and I know
there's some indications around the
community center that we may need to
look at those so we will look at those
but if there's any others then please
don't hesitate to it give us some
Direction
it's just a quiz on the visitor centers
we've actually decreased the
photocopping charge down to the same as
the other two places in the council I
just we I think originally we put it
back up to make sure the visitors center
was the visitor center and we didn't get
a whole lot of foot traffic just because
of photocopying and um are they there
actually to do people's photocoping and
I query whether we should just leave it
the same charges we've had
foreign through your worship the um the
reason the change was made was for
consistency across the organization we'd
had some queries about why it costs more
and one venue and and not in another
um it can be one of those question one
of those conversations we have as part
of the long-term plan whether this is a
service we want to provide Through The
Visitor Center or not
um and you know that's that's something
we can we can look at but there was the
reasoning behind that one
councilor McFarlane
yes uh thank you worship just through to
Lorne and I do note um we're discussing
that uh 80 year old free swimming our
last mayor of the worship I think we had
a discussion regarding Speedos of the
own so
um I just said that vividly going
through I won't be having that
conversation no no no just
obviously uh looking at the the various
methodologies and mechanisms that we use
to cross here do you think we've gone
tight enough with these fees because
obviously looking at where um
some of the councilors have indicated a
one percent across our operational
budget across uh the the council do you
think we've gone tight enough into here
for user user pay
uh through your worship this is actually
an area where one of the other levers
that Council can pull to help reduce
rates so there can be some additional
increases at the some areas where you
haven't we haven't increased so
cemeteries is an area where we haven't
actually applied increases this year
we've introduced a couple of new charges
one of the charges was always just
wasn't on our list some of the other
venues like the Matilda Community Center
we haven't reviewed the charges there
for some time either so those are those
are levers that the councilors can use
to try and
um decrease rates further by increasing
fees and charges so it's more of a use
of haze system so again up to elected
members to guide us in that
Council mcphire
I think you worship I definitely just
bring up the visitor center and one that
councilor Gardens talking about I
personally don't want people going there
photocoping there's I want the people
there to be selling the air town
getting getting them to go to the things
that we want to I think that's one of
the things I agree with you there
definitely I think the Venus charges
definitely ornay for the James coming
Wing are very light
um going by the background I've got with
venues and things the higher costs have
gone up a lot in the last couple of
years
I think we're very light but I guess
it's a starting point but I think we
definitely can look at that as a council
right across the board and I think even
my Tara and all the other areas we've
got to look at it otherwise down the
track we've got to have to put it up a
lot to be realistic of realistic costing
so thanks thank you very much
thank you councilor is the wiggle room I
know we're talking about different
venues is their wiggle room as well with
the multi-sports complex as well
potentially there's another venue three
Russia at the multi Sports Complex have
increased some of their charges so they
were one of the one of the areas that
did look at that and Martin had done a
lot of work uh pricing against
neighboring councils and landed on those
lending on those increases so he has he
has already done that in his area so
it's probably at a maximum already yeah
cool thank you uh councilor Stringer oh
yeah thanks you worship
um
I understand that we probably use some
third-party or Outsource for some of
these Services have we taken into
account that we're running costs might
be going up in the next 12 months as
well obviously with wage increases have
we well can we account for that somehow
but through your worship the the figures
are based on what we know at the time uh
so the property group in particular just
doing a lot of our resource consenting
and stuff they have assisted Us in
providing and providing these fees so
they worked with uh staff on reviewing
those fees to get to where they had
there was no indication from them at the
stage that there is changing so fingers
crossed
councilor Dixon thank you worship I just
have one other queer units around the
cat trap pile
um ten dollars a week which is fine but
a 50 bond is probably quite High because
people have to outlay sixty dollars and
they have spoken to me about that and
said you know they would like to get a
cat trap but
um that outlaves sixty dollars although
they get the bond back they feel it's
just too much too much for them
I think it's something we can look at
yeah yeah if that's a barrier to entry
then sure Council Hotel
um is the one person who's hired the cat
trap this year uh you pay your fifty
dollar Bond and no more and they take
the ten dollar a week out in terms of
what they give you as your refund
so um just it's fifty dollars that you
pay up front not 60.
yeah it's still five weeks worth of use
yeah up front yeah
better to know how many of those have
been nicked if any
um too yeah
any further questions I guess I got one
more for Lorne and it's probably a bit
ambitious but
if we're to re-look at those venues how
much do you realistically think we may
be able to find in there or am I asking
way too much
detailed analysis
um I can get it won't be big dollars
um I I figure they're sitting in my head
at the moment and again without actually
seeing the numbers in front of me
um I believe that the Matilda
Service uh Community Center for example
may have had eleven thousand dollars
worth of Revenue last year for hires so
it's not significant money but every
every little dollar helps towards
reducing a rate payers increase
yeah
thank you for that little night and
sorry just a supplementary to that with
the charges for the James Wing
has that been accounted for like in the
the rate increase well the overall
budget with those current figures yeah
okay
uh cancer got on
we should take into account too that
those public buildings we need to make
use of them because they're for the
public and um if we put the charges too
high and even have empty rooms we're
just cutting noses off
good point good point uh any further
comment councilor Phillips
uh just a reminder if you everyone's
thinking about putting out the prices of
military Community Center that building
was put there for no cost to any
ratepayer within the district just a
reminder
thank you for that Council well pup
any further discussion on fees and
charges I think we've given decent
somewhat directions uh to lawn a in
terms of where we might be some areas
that we could could look at
it
so my question in your worship is
the recommendation there is that this
these fees and charges as they are
proposed here for the be adopted
um if you're suggesting you want to
allowed to take that direction away and
come back with the annual plan on the
27th of June meeting to do your formal
adoption of the fees and charges is that
what you suggested
yep yep so so you're not going to pass
this recommendation here today because
you don't want to adopt this you'll get
you well adopted on the 27th of June
yes so I guess the recommendation would
be that the report be received and um
yeah feedback noted um I just had one
more question as well
uh
just around regulatory I was just
looking at some of the licenses do we
have given the Bible and think we don't
have any flexibility about increasing
those no no three worship a lot of the
regulatory ones I stepped down sit down
by central government so they buy
statute and we we're a price taker
rather than a price setter
cool thank you for that
okay do I have a mover that's the report
be received and that uh
I just written this up if it's all right
we'll see the report be received and
feedback considered
um preparation for formal adoption at 27
June council meeting for fees and
charges
Council on actor now and a secondary
councilor Phillips any further
discussion
all those in favor please say aye
aye and against the motion is carried
thank you very much councilors and
everyone in attendance I will close with
a short prayer may the Open Sky group
your uplisted face made the pulls
Stillness fill your mind and soul and
may you know your the presence of Christ
throughout the Journey of your life amen
thank you everybody